إنه شعور رائع كما تعلم لقد لعبت
المعرض هنا من قبل آه لقد كنت حزينًا لأنني
فاتني العام الماضي ولكن أنا سعيد بالعودة وآه تعلم أنه من
الجيد أن ألعب
البطولة كما تعلم أنني أحب دائمًا أن
أكون هنا يبدو الأمر كذلك  المنزل لذا
أتطلع لرؤية جميع المشجعين ما
رأيك في القرعة الصعبة أعني أنني كنت
أتوقع أن تكون صعبة بالتأكيد آه
الجميع يريد أن يأتي ويلعب هنا ولكن
آه كما تعلم آه أنا أحب المنافسة الصعبة
أنا أنا'  أنا مستعد لذلك وآمل أن
يساعدني الجمهور أه في التحفيز
والفوز بالمباريات، سيكون الجمهور AB
خلفك بالتأكيد، ليس أقله بالطبع
لأنك أول
امرأة عربية مسلمة وإفريقية تصل إلى
نهائي إحدى البطولات الأربع الكبرى و  الجماهير هنا
تحب رؤيتك دائمًا، ما مدى أهمية
هذا التمثيل بالنسبة لك في هذه
الرياضة، أعتقد أنه مهم جدًا
أثناء نشأتي، أه أردت أن أكون
ملهمًا من اللاعبين الآخرين ولكن أه عندما
ترى ترى لاعبين مختلفين من
بلدان مختلفة كما تعلم  لكن لا يوجد أحد
أه من اللوحة العربية
ولكنك تريد أن تستلهم من ذلك، كما
تعلم أنه كان لدينا الكثير من
اللاعبين المختلفين ولكنك دائمًا تريد الضغط أكثر
وإظهار أنه ليس من المستحيل
الفوز بإحدى البطولات الأربع الكبرى بشكل خاص و  من الذي
ألهمك عندما كبرت ألا
يكذب عليك أمي كانت أمي
مصدر إلهامي لقد علمتني كيف أكون تلك
الفتاة القوية لأحاول دائمًا الفوز بكل
شيء وأه نعم من الواضح عندما
كبرت قليلاً أنا اه أنا  شاهدت آه
كيم سيرز وهي تلعب آه، إنها فتاة لطيفة جدًا وقد
التقيت بها الآن أيضًا، لذا أه آه إنها
ملهمة حقًا ما هو الأمر المتعلق
بالرياضة وما مدى المسؤولية التي
تشعر بها نوعًا ما لمساعدة
هؤلاء الشباب ودعمهم أثناء تقدمهم على ما
أعتقد  من المهم أن تكون لديك
علاقة معينة مع هؤلاء اللاعبين،
خاصة أن الانتقال من مستوى الناشئين
إلى الاحتراف أمر صعب للغاية وأنا
أعلم أنك تعلم ذلك، فهم أكثر
ودية مع الناشئين وأقل صداقة مع وسائل الإعلام
في حلبة الاحتراف وأه أشعر
بذلك  هذا اللاعب الشاب الذي ربما
لا يتمتع بخبرة كبيرة وهم
جدد ويريدون العثور على
وجه ودود، لذا فهم يعرفونني، فأنا
منفتح دائمًا للتحدث معه حتى أحب
الدردشة حول أشياء عشوائية، ربما  لا
يتعلق الأمر بالموضة لأنني لا أجيد هذا
المستوى ولكن في أي أشياء أخرى
يسعدني تقديم أي نصيحة وأشعر
أنها يجب أن تكون جولة ودية أه
أه ولكن أيضًا منافسة شرسة
على  المحكمة، كيف تعتقد أنك
فعلت حتى الآن، ما هي الإستراتيجية لعام
2024، أعتقد أنه كان لدي
استعداد جيد حقًا، كما تعلم أه ربما لم
أدخل في المنافسة جيدًا،
أعتقد أنني بحاجة إلى المزيد من المباريات ولهذا السبب
ألعب معك  أعرف كامل أه أبو ظبي
الدوحة دبي لأجهز نفسي ولكن
بالتأكيد أتطلع للعب هنا
وبدء موسمي أه أفضل بكثير
مما فعلت في بطولة أستراليا المفتوحة، إنه
عام أولمبي، الموسم مزدحم بما فيه الكفاية كما
تعلم في عام عادي  ما هي
الخطة، الخطة هي أن تكون بصحة جيدة، كما تعلم كما قلت،
إنه أمر صعب،
العام بالفعل صعب للغاية مع وجود أربع
بطولات كبرى، إضافة نوع آخر من
البطولات الأربع الكبرى أمر صعب للغاية ولكن كما تعلم، دعنا نرى
كيف ستسير الأمور  أعرفني، هدفي هو أن
أستمر حقًا، لذا دعونا نرى كيف ستسير الأمور، لقد
تحدثت ليس فقط عن
التنس في الآونة الأخيرة، ولكن عن مدى صعوبة أن تكون
من هذه المنطقة في هذه المنطقة عندما
ترى ما يحدث في غزة، وكيف كان
الوضع في  غزة أثرت على موسمك
وأنت كفرد الأمر صعب بالنسبة
لي
أشعر أحيانا عندما أكون سعيدا
أضحك لا ينبغي أن أكون كما تعلم
بسبب الأطفال والنساء والرجال الذين يموتون
كل يوم حتى بصراحة أه صحفي
أنت تعرف أنه الأمر صعب للغاية
لرؤية ذلك وأه أتمنى أن
تستيقظ الكلمة وتفعل شيئًا
حيال ذلك، أحاول تقديم الدعم بقدر ما
أستطيع، أحاول التحدث بقدر
ما أستطيع اه ولكن نعم أنا كذلك  لن أصمت،
سأتحدث
وأتحدث عن هذا، هذا
شيء إنساني يجب القيام به، لذلك
لا أحاول الدخول في السياسة أو
أي شيء آخر، هذا أمر يخصني كإنسان  كونك
تحاول القيام بالشيء الصحيح، فقط تحدث
عن العمل الذي تقوم به خارج
الملعب، وأعتقد أنه من المهم أن
أظهر الجانب الإنساني مني وأردت دائمًا
المساعدة، لذا أه إطلاق
مؤسستي وأن أكون جزءًا من
منظمة مذهلة  باعتباري برنامج الأغذية العالمي أه في
العالم، أحاول أه مساعدة الناس في
الوقت الحالي، كما تعرفون المزيد في غزة مع برنامج الأغذية العالمي
ومع مؤسستي، آمل أن أحاول
مساعدة بلدي ومساعدة أفريقيا
بشكل عام، وآمل أن أساعد
الأطفال  والنساء المحتاجات هو هذا الذي
يهيئك لحياة ما بعد التنس،
أعني أن هذا هو المكان الذي تريد فيه تركيز
انتباهك، وأعتقد أن ذلك نعم،
تحتاج إلى إعداد شيء معين
لتعرفه بعد الحياة المهنية وأنا أساعد
الآخرين هو  أحد الأشياء التي أريد
التركيز عليها وبالتأكيد تعلم أنني
شعرت أنني عندما كنت صغيرًا
ربما كنت بحاجة إلى المساعدة أيضًا، لذا إذا كان بإمكاني
تقديم هذه المساعدة لطفل أعتقد أن ذلك
سيغير العالم